this 128 foot long super yacht runs
almost 14 million dollars to purchase
but that's just the beginning of its
expenses
City it's a resort and it moves but
imagine if that Resort sat on top of one
of the planet's saltiest wettest
environments yacht owners can also
expect to pay 10 to 20 percent of the
yacht's value each year simply to
maintain it super Yachts or Yachts
longer than 82 feet can sell for
hundreds of millions of dollars this
means maintenance could be tens of
millions per year here's what goes into
this super Yachts estimated annual
budget of nearly 1.9 million dollars
welcome aboard snowbird
costs that up even before owner set sail
dockets cheese are very expensive they
range from three dollars and fifty cents
a foot to 750 a foot per day dockage
fees can be so high for super yachts in
part because there's a large demand for
a limited number of spaces but if owners
keep their Yachts docked they could face
other large maintenance expenses all the
works of the bottom of the vessel gets
up with oysters and clams and
Barnacles a lot of these Electronics
they get fouled up if they sit dormant
for a long time it's definitely better
to use it than let it sit well docked
the yacht can connect to the Marina's
power grid for basic operations but when
it's out at Sea this 368-ton vessel
requires fuel
a lot of it for someone like myself I
call this boat yoga
what we have here is the day tank this
holds approximately 800 gallons of fuel
see the red that's the amount that's in
the tank in total this yacht can hold
almost 12 000 gallons of fuel plus other
water Vehicles like its jet skis and
support boat will need even more gas
generally we burn anywhere from 60
gallons an hour to 120 gallons an hour
at around four and a half dollars a
gallon it costs approximately 360
thousand dollars per year to fuel
Snowbird but day-to-day maintenance is
actually the fourth largest operating
cost
and it can get messy today we're going
to be changing out the crankcase
ventilation filter that keeps your
turbos and your after cooler from
getting gummed up and it also helps
reduce oil consumption and reduce air
pollution by further combustion inside
the engine this part probably costs 60
70 to replace but it has immeasurable
value in prolonging the longevity of
your Motors maintaining the engines on a
yacht like Snowbird typically costs
around sixty thousand dollars a year and
you're looking at Parts time and the
materials involved to change the oils
and keep everything up and going that's
just below deck super yacht owners also
need to invest in keeping the rest of
the yacht in pristine condition like the
teak flooring teak is typically used on
Yachts because it's a weather resistant
luxury material but it's also
challenging to maintain
when we scrub the tea oftentimes it only
lasts roughly a week or two depending on
the traffic on board it wants to go back
to its natural color and you know
between rain and rinsing it down you
kind of wash away all that you know hard
work that you've done
annually the teak flooring costs about
eighteen thousand dollars to maintain
adding on smaller expenses you're
already looking at just over one million
dollars but by far there's one cost for
maintaining super Yachts that completely
surpasses the others the crew
the estimated budget for snowbird's crew
is over eight hundred thousand dollars
per year and that's because super Yachts
must always have a crew even when docked
yeah take care of the teak the pain wash
windows Machinery rust never sleeps
maintenance never stops cost towards
their health insurance travel expenses
uniforms and cell phone bills can add
thousands to the budget adding in crew
expenses brings the annual operating
cost estimate to nearly 1.9 million
dollars a year but that's only when
there are no major repairs or
maintenance
while owners generally spend around 10
percent a year in maintenance costs for
New Super Yachts it's kind of a
guideline but as she gets three years or
five years or hits her 10 year it's
going to be more than 10 percent every
five years or so super yacht owners have
to Shell out for one of their largest
expenses paint shops are sometimes from
a hundred thousand to a million bucks
depending on your size of your boat
paint is about eighteen hundred dollars
an inch salt in the water and air
corrodes the yacht's paint to repaint
the entire yacht it needs to be hauled
out of the water then it can take months
to complete a fresh paint job there are
also other major potential expenses some
yacht owners need to spend hundreds of
thousands of dollars every few years on
detailed inspections and if a yacht
fails an inspection repairing or
replacing it could run two hundred
thousand dollars or more certain boats
you can't get the engines out you have
to cut a hole in the side and then
re-weld it re-certify the hull now
you're into the multi-millions to change
out an engine to recoup some of these
costs super yacht owners will rent out
their vessels the charter fee for this
super yacht ranges from 125 to 145 000
per week that covers the boat and the
crew but renters also need to pay for
additional expenses like fuel food and
customs fees plus there's a customary
tip of 18 to 25 percent for the crew
members at best super yacht owners might
break even on maintenance costs with
income earned from chartering I don't
think it's a profitable situation at
best they're covering their salaries and
the boats weigh as it travels wear and
tear is always there and the money would
have to go back into the vessel if you
didn't properly maintain your vessel
your value would decrease most people
that buy Yachts of this size and the
stature really want to take care of them
foreign